right welcome everyone
so start this cabinet and can have
apologies for absence please on non
thank you disclosures of interest any
disclosures sorry counselor parrot
that's right that's fine the chair just
to say that I am the county councillor
for the item with reference to barely
land I don't I don't believe I've got a
problem but I have been working very
closely with the parish council Thank
You councillor Perry any more
disclosures of interest I'll take that
as a no so minutes can I come can we
confirm and sign the minutes of the
meeting held on tenth of verb yes I know
page six every four years it is it
should be every three years
Thank You councillor Harvey
I fight with with that that was actually
on the minutes are we all happy with the
minutes the great thank you
matters to be referred to council nan a
transformation in digital portfolio item
for councillor Cargill particularly that
obviously these are the proposed
performance management framework for the
future for this council I'd like to
think that it's an overview at the
moment which is holding the council to
its promises I like this to be as robust
and transparent as as possible so that
we have full accountability on these and
it also gives us an opportunity for
continual improvement I do feel that
that one of the things we don't
challenge ourselves enough on is
improving our standards and that's
something perhaps we should consider as
part and parcel ongoing process on a
regular basis otherwise I have very
little else to say apart from that
obviously these are of trial and see how
it's going if we need a minute this mend
it but let's make this council the best
it can possibly be
yes can I ask a question about the Cape
one of the kpi's the pace 33 the
proposed target for waist and now
obviously coming falling on from the
green waist charges you now reducing the
target for percentage of household waste
sent to reuse recycling and composting
from 61 percent to 45 percent or there
abouts what what plans are being taken
to mitigate that to try and keep up what
it has been up until now an absolutely
excellent that record on recycling for
this council an average rate at the
moment unfortunately in the UK has
stagnated somewhere around about forty
five forty six percent that would put us
about mid well drop us down quite a few
places obviously in the league table
from current well maybe we will move
that the education food and to encourage
people to recycle more that's the key
because in the grave in as I've
mentioned before we have approximately a
third of that grade things should be in
the other bins so there is plenty to go
that as I understand if you don't mind
me coming back we are currently about
10th in the performance league tables I
thought but we certainly were in that
top echelon of recycling councils and
it's just disappointing that you are
planning to go quite so far down as 40
to 45 percent in quite so far down I
know the some of the reasoning but I
want to know what the mitigation is what
what extra efforts will you be taking
making in order to be able to try
but we still are as performing to the
standards that we we have done up until
now councillor Shenton then councillor
Pemberton and council will yeah I mean
we're not a we're not aiming to do to
achieve 46% this year the government
target is 50% but we have to be
realistic obviously at this point in
time it is I can't come back to it is
all about education and enforcement
though it will be coupled with
enforcement we have to get tough
obviously on this and what education is
by far the preferred route on this Thank
You Chancellor Shenton councillor
Pemberton thank thank you leader I think
perhaps also to give councillor Junod
and members of the audience some comfort
you'll note that the the target in
relation to the waste per household
remains unchanged I think you also need
to consider in relation to the next KPI
that there is an anticipation and an
expectation that there will be a
commence there will be an increase in
composting so in terms of that which is
coming to that there may well be a
reduction and some degree that will be
offset by the increase in composting by
those who choose to compost more than to
use the the green waste but I think the
other side is that the residual waste
per household target isn't changing in
cancer centres absolutely right around
the education piece and they'll be an
ongoing set of messages to to ensure
that we're as good as we possibly can be
do you want to interview mr. Chancellor
as well
[Music]
yeah it was just very quick one if I can
lay that still so the 385 as cancer
cargo I was pointed out but we will look
to review this this is not set in stone
it's a starting point at the moment 385
is good but it could be better and I
recognize that we have to monitor this
and we will this is not set in stone we
will amend this if we feel that it's
it's actually understated Thank You
councillor Huggins
thank you just it was just a point out
about the composting that individual
households I'm sure will be being more
proactive about the composting
themselves and I was wondering if in
future surveys that we have with
residents if we could add a questioning
as to how many actually itself
composting so that would help to get a
better figured that and I think we've
also got to be minded that a lot more of
retailers and then I'm going towards you
know having better packaging or no
packaging which would sort of reduce the
waste as well so frankly Richards Thank
You chair I've got a few things if I may
say first of all on page 14 of the
report section of streets
specifically 3.1 those are our
performance updates being reported the
cabinet forum on a quarterly basis it
also reported to the scrutiny committee
I'm assuming that's neighbor sites and
by confirming this it will continue to
come to over you in scrutiny and just
wanted to make that point and get it yes
good
page 13 1.1 we talked about their
process in consultation obviously one of
the integral parts of avian scrutiny is
performance review I wonder why scrutiny
committee haven't been included in the
protis and consultation in coming up
with these KPIs and if indeed we can
ensure that does happen going forward we
do have
actually got a list of three things here
specifically that we would want to be
considered during that consultation
process I think the point is notable in
future we'll make sure you consulted
marvelous thank you page seventeen cp1
a says shakespeare's england to provide
an annual update on activity to the
overview and scrutiny committee i'm
obviously completely oblivious to the
fact that i've been added in there we
set our work program on first meeting
that we have as a scrutiny committee
whilst I've got no particular issue with
the the suggestion it obviously is down
to the committee's that set that that
agenda
Azzam went agreed caliber bottom
traditionally that's where they've come
and reported so that's an oversight that
they weren't in your work program I
recall as chairman of the uncertainty
they'd been pretty much the first thing
on the list right if all cabinet members
just need to bring the people that have
the questions in Ruggiano death it's not
a question it's just simply reiterate
what Cancer Center said was in my first
when I open this I said we want to be
robust transparent and continual
improvement and that's exactly what we
intend to do so we will be looking at
these in future I just wanted to raise a
question that councillor Curtis had
mentioned at the ovm scrutiny committee
which was on page 18 cp1 C which is
about the benefits from commentary City
of Culture in the target is by March
2021 to develop a program to support the
City of Culture and Commonwealth Games I
think the question was wouldn't the
program already be underway by then and
which case should we be having an
earlier target than is printed there I
think despite what the target says there
is continual communication going
with the Coventry about the City of
Culture and obviously if we can do
things sooner we will bite so with that
we have two members of the public who
have questions on this issue mr. nori
you have a question on behalf of
Stratford climate action would you
likely like to come to a microphone
please hello thank you as chair of staff
for climate action obviously the target
that concerns me most is carbon
emissions and transport is the single
biggest source of emissions within the
district as you're aware 56 percent of
the emissions within the district we
understand that the task and finish
group weren't fully able to treat these
this source of emissions to their
satisfaction within the time allotted to
them due to difficulties of working with
the County Council in that time frame so
we were just wondering if considering
these emissions and considering all the
possible ways of addressing them would
be a priority for the climate change
panel that has just been set up thank
you I think one of the things I would
say on this is that transport emissions
are a very significant issue they're not
just a matter for the district council
as you probably know I mean the
government is thinking of phasing out
all internal combustion engines by 2035
which is well after 2030 not only that
at the moment of course there does not
seem to be any obvious replacement for
fossil fuels in HGVs so the chances I
would say of actually making a
significant amount of progress on this
in
he's probably going to be challenging
the question you asked about
collaborating with the County Council I
think again it's much more I think an
issue for central government and
regulations than it is fry the district
councils or County Council's we will
look at what we may be able to do to
tackle the emissions but there may well
be other things that we can achieve far
more on in the shorter any other cabinet
member got questions yes there's an
opportunity for other members as Captain
to have any questions that of Stephen
whilst he's here but if not the last one
I'm thinking mister passing him
oh right we we understand that the
cabinet would like to share in the
high-level climate officer white
district council intends to a point does
the council have reason to believe that
like District Council will be willing to
share is is it reasonable to worry about
such a no the sharing arrangement might
lead to the officers time being spread a
little thin Lee if I can pick up the
first thing they deputy leader myself
and the chief exec have meetings with
our counterparts at Water District the
idea of cooperating on issues on climate
change was actually moved to death our
last meeting very high-level at the
moment but to me there seems to be
absolutely no point in every district
trying to reinvent its own wheel so if
we can actually cooperate together and
work together it is going to be I think
extremely beneficial well I think this
will be particularly important is in
terms of influencing government and I
think in that sense it's not just
working cooperatively with water
district it's working cooperatively with
the County Council with carbon-free and
with the other districts and boroughs
within the county there are meetings set
up to look at planning issues with the
forum that contains all representatives
from all of those bodies personally
hoping and we'll push that the issues on
climate change actually feature in those
discussions and it will be much more
powerful for us to try and influence
government in terms of what needs doing
then it would be being a lone voice one
thing I would say is that working
together with Water District it does not
mean we will not do work for ourselves
very specific to this district I'm
September - thank you I think I would
say no you don't need to worry about an
officer being spread thing but the whole
point of the type of climate change
officers the Warwick envisage I mean
that we envisage in a number of other
authorities envisaged is that these are
strategic people they're not getting
into the mine hei of every single policy
that's it's that they're setting an
agenda and then for example our policy
development team planning development
team and any other team in our
environmental services team they then do
the detail work and further need so I
don't think it would be a fair summation
to say that if we were to share a
high-level senior officer role that that
would dilute quite the reverse actually
I think you you actually achieve an
economy that enables progress to be made
more quickly so I've given the nature of
the people that work that we're both
talking about I think actually there's a
lot of synergy when there are two quite
closely aligned authorities potentially
to share that you wouldn't necessarily
share it for example with Birmingham
itself because the synergies are
different and they've got different an
approach I think just to give you that
comfort that would be the better way of
doing it in
but as I understand it one district
counts all have got a sustainability
officer and the role has been over about
20 years in Stratford we used to have a
an agenda 21 officer about 20 years ago
and that role changed into being a
climate change of this with the previous
climate change panel and that role
disappeared about eight or nine years
ago and there was all sorts of energy
efficiency things that I mean the the
still here in your housing department
and you used to do lots of important
energy efficiency things and community
engagement and all sorts of functions
and roles which passively climate change
plan do you not think it would be a good
idea to have some role like that as well
I think that is probably a consideration
for the climate change panel when it is
set up the one thing that is very clear
we have a commitment to tackling climate
change we not only have a commitment to
looking at the mitigation impacts but
also equally importantly we have to
consider how we adapt to what are going
to be the impacts of climate change and
so believe me there is an awful lot of
work to do and will have to make sure
within the funding constraints we've got
that we can address them yeah okay
thanks
so without further ado I'm settled on
page 30 37 we have the document we
published about trapper district and in
the gray hatch area on the left - page
37 we talked about internationally over
the page for the headings is
international in relation to our
cultural and tourism push and yet under
CP 1 a and C P 1 B we don't mention
International whatsoever
now given that we've now got to the
stage of an officer level dialogue with
overseas cities with mr. perks traveling
through show last year alongside with
portfolio holder and myself I believe
that we should include as part of our
strategy an international rather than a
national undersea p1a and/or cp1 beef
I'm the requested that is included Thank
You counselor careful I think if one
actually looks to the creation of an
inward investment strategy that is meant
to be international and not just limited
to the UK but I do take the point and we
probably do need to look much more
closely at international although what I
would also say on that is that Coventry
and why don't you let do an awful lot of
work on the international investment
saying much of which is potentially of
significant benefit to this district so
as you know I now sit on on the cultural
tourism side of that any indeed but I
think
hassey p1a when we're talking about
lifting the profile we should be looking
at least in words even though we're
doing it to include the word
international under CP 1a i I think we
can pick that up and make sure an
appropriate addition he's 14
Thank You mr. with that if we turn to
page 13 the recommendations are there
recommendations 2 & 3 there's a whole
schedule of increases in schedule 2 part
1 of page 70 you will see all the such
schedule to pay for part 1 on page 17
those are all the the current charges
for a long charges for the cars or the
increases can you see there and if
you're interested in coaches and marie's
then on page 75 you'll find those
some of the other key points are permit
holders so the obviously these parking
order is a proposal something anything
that you've mentioned and just right at
the outset because it has to go out for
consultation if it's approved today a
quickly a few approvers so the permit
holders we rationalized three separate
passes or the passes of the or permits
at the letter center into two and those
are shown on pages 70 and 71 and 73
basically we tried just taking an
opportunity to have two to two
challenges they're coming to the the
issue that is concerned a lot of people
recently the over 65s permit so this is
the one that's going to increase from 10
pounds to 25 pounds and then in addition
the proposal is to restrict the parking
from 10 a.m. in the morning for a
maximum of 4 hours during the day and
that's that's shown on page 73 and the
car parks that can be used for it are
the Swans Nest car park Windsor Street
car park and recreation they brand car
park from 10:00 a.m. with standard
either waiting times in many of our car
parks in the process and those are on
page
so along have moved from 24 hours to 72
hours and we've made that standardize
that non-standard car parks are
highlighted in two other sections one
point five point three and one point
five point four that shows that the the
car parks that are not covered by the 72
hour limit and the other consistencies
really regard couch and lorries it's
charting for up to 12 hours and up to 24
hours
those have been standardized and they're
on page 40 so the basically what we'll
have enough today is if this is approved
it will then go out through a statutory
six-week consultation period during
which organizations be the County etc
residents can make representations as
long as there's nothing if you like that
we need to chase some substantive change
we can move ahead with it if there is
some kind of substantive change that we
need to make then we'll have to come
back to cabinet to further approve that
and then go through the six week cycle
again assuming that there are no changes
just for this for this purpose we have
the amended charges and permits are
aiming we're able to get those including
June or July so the one of the things
that we thought was brought up as well
always about enforcement a spending
parser this morning with the enforcement
team at bridge foot going through how it
would be enforced whether the pda's can
handle it and yes it can and one final
thought on this is that remember our
budget has gone a certain amount of
growth in there from this particular
proposal so I am looking for
is to be approved Thank You councillor
Shenton members of cabinet any comments
councillor Whaley Hogenson councillor
Perry councillor shanton can he
specially why we're charging for lorries
given the fact that it's actually a real
legal requirement for drivers to take a
rest of eight hours especially the long
the long haul drivers and that we are
wanting to encourage businesses in into
the area and how those charges compare
to other other cities and towns in the
area
mr. perks in terms of why we do have a
charge is primarily in the back of the
ledger sense that we have a charge we
were having an issue at one stage where
lawyers were diverting from the m-40
where they were super charged them to
stay driving through the residential
area instead of parking up in Stratford
which was something that residents
didn't find very popular and was causing
so pollution we're on our Road so that
the denominator and was introduced to
discourage that behavior originally and
I think that sort of been maintained as
part of this revision Thank You mr.
Berg's council Perry Thank You leader I
just wanted to highlight and give my
thanks to councillor Shenton and the
team for the diligent approach over the
last three or four months that you've
been working on this I think it's very
comprehensive that someone who
occasionally goes to Solihull where we
charged an absolute arm and a lake to
park and I'm particularly keen I'm
pleased that you know we've come down to
the 25 pounds for the concessionary
rates and I'm sure with all the
publicity that you've had you're going
to get an awful lot more applying for
that particular
season you know did that particular
permit so I think I think you've done a
very thorough and diligent job and
please extend my thanks on to the rest
of your team
Thank You councillor Perry councillor
Ralph
the reason why what went first is
because the counselor concerned who is
the warden one of the counselors
concerned raised it at an overview and
scrutiny committee so I did say that I
would report from the overview and
scrutiny committee about the fact that
permits are to be valid from 10:00 a.m.
allergies on the recreation ground that
he wanted to it raised because at the
moment there are lots of residents who
currently take their dogs for an
early-morning walk on the recreation
ground and therefore he felt that those
people would be disadvantaged as a
result of the change and it's the
recreation ground in particular maybe
councillor fill you in on the details
okay just just a very small point
counselor Perry said that Solihull is
expensive this will bring us in line
with exactly the same prices and silly
old charge I just wanted to make that
because I'm a member of bed and we know
the first point I want to make is is
councillor Shenton has been to the bit
meeting and he knows the feelings of the
businesses very strongly against
increasing the car parking charges and
once again is a death knell to our town
but you will get many many responses on
that so let me talk about the 10:00 a.m.
start I mean to be honest with you I
think you're being really petty here now
I go down to the recreation ground every
single day I have done for the last two
weeks come looking after my daughter's
dog and between nine and ten there are
hundreds of places to park for people
that work in the town but down at the
bottom of the wreck there's about half a
dozen people at about nine o'clock uh
past eight nine o'clock that take their
dog for a walk and they've all got the
over 65s parking
now are we going to be that petty to
actually affect a handful of people are
we going to put money into parking
services going down that ha plus 9
ticketing a handful of people I mean
really it's such a small amount of
people can we just take away the 10
o'clock at the recreation ground I
absolutely agree with you with Windsor
Street and with swans nest because
that's where the businesses businesses
park but the actual recreation ground
itself I think it's being incredibly
petty and a bit heartless of this
council and it won't go down terribly
well with the residents thank you
I think council Ralph that if you
listened carefully to councillor Shenton
that if we made any changes to this that
means it would have to go out for
another six weeks of consultation and we
would lose quite a lot of money for as
you put it the sake of six people I just
wanted to make that point
councillor Pemberton thank you I'm just
going to come back on the question of
parking in Solihull
so just to be clear that the council
Park in Solihull
it's a nought to two hours and it's two
pounds 7c where we have a one-hour of
one pound 20 and for up to two hours is
to plan 40 so it's cheaper than Solihull
Solihull then go to two to three hours
at 350 yep three hours were at 350 but
we will give you four hours for five
pounds because over and so no we're not
more expensive than solid Hall and
that's leaving aside the NCP car parks
which are eye watering lis expensive
compared to this town we're not I'm
sorry we're not I'm just looking at the
right there okay
councillor Harvey simple question -
counselor shame - we got a date set for
when a consultation process is intended
to start virtually straight away in
actual fact we just need approval then
we can move on the order is ready to go
Thank You counselor it should
is there a or do you have issues all
ready to go do you have a web link that
we can circulate to our parish councils
it'll be well circulated and a we pushed
out everywhere yeah cancel the the
parish councils can be will be contacted
gee it'd be in the press there were your
web link that it will be properly
publicized okay
councillor Shenton briefly please it
won't one pushback on the under the
wreck if if walking the dog nine o'clock
the morning is a problem then we still
have the one hour free at Bridge was it
councilor centered sort of Noma
interventions for members of cabinets
the recommendation on page 39 our
members of cabinet happy with that
recommendation thanking members of
cabinet
so moving on revenue of which at one
between councillor Harvey
oh sorry I've done on run too far
it's capital first councillor Harvey
capital budget monitoring please Thank
You mr. chairman the purpose of this
paper is to keep members informed of the
progress made over the first ten months
of the year in undertaking the council's
intended level of capital expenditure
this year they were one on page 79
demonstrates the intention to undertake
expenditure of six million pounds this
year including section 106 projects
taking into account additional funds of
2.6 million pounds of budgeted for this
year this will result in the balance of
the council's accumulated capital
receipts and grants being reduced over
the year from 5.5 million pounds to 2.6
million pounds paragraph 1.5 indicates
that capital expenditure of seven
hundred and four thousand pounds has
already been undertaken and a further 1
million pounds has been committed by the
end of January in the first 10 months of
the year therefore the sums spent or
committed amounted to twenty eight point
four percent of this year's available
budget of six million Paris members may
have noticed in particular from Appendix
1 the receipts from the sale of
previously owned houses sold under the
right to bow to buy now amount this year
to over a million pound with an
additional four hundred and sixty four
thousand pounds having been received
during the period under review appendix
2 on pages 89 to 93 provides summary
information concerning the various
projects yet to be funded through
section 106 agreements I'd like to draw
attention again to a single element that
is the degree to which the amount the
about funds allocated under section of
106 agreements relates to affordable
housing over the period in November
20:19 to January 2020 this increased by
a further 200,000 pounds at present 2.8
million pounds of the three point seven
million pounds of section 106 agreements
in value in other words more than
three-quarters of amount available is
earmarked in relation to the provision
of affordable housing I a therefore that
the current position on capital
expenditure and income for the period to
the end of January 2020 is noted any
comments or questions members of
cabinets councillor JUnit as you say
they there is an earmarked provision for
affordable housing are you sure that you
can deliver the actual you know within
the timetable and that that you you can
deliver the affordable housing that is
that you indicate the straightforward
answer that is no he can't because we
currently are not in control of
receiving bids we respond to bids as and
when they come in and we have responded
in the last six months to two bids
indeed we responded to one last week on
Thursday for nearly half million pounds
but it is well noted and the reason why
I have on the last two occasions are
going to reported on the capital
expenditure that I have drawn attention
to the affordable housing figure and
there and the the balances and indeed
I've had a discussion this afternoon
with the chief executive about the
council being in a position to be more
proactive about spending money for
affordable housing despite all the
difficulties that that that would entail
and in the practical sense about when
money is received when schemes can be
worked up when land is available
etcetera etcetera
I take the spirit in which the question
is asked to no I'm sympathetic to it I
don't I don't think anybody in the
council wants to see money that has been
accumulated or that is accumulator
affordable housing being left sat in the
you know in the bank balance it is there
to be used and we we will endeavor to do
what we can to ensure that that happens
for mayor council harvey i think that
does illustrate the big advantages of
looking at the numbers in depth on
making sure the analysis is there and
very thorough thank you i just again to
give some comfort the first thing to say
is that developer contributions per
typically around affordable housing
which a time-limited
we will find a way to ensure that those
developer contributions are used for the
purpose that they are intended which is
to provide affordable housing and we're
not in the business of giving money back
to developers
I would also to give some further
comfort there have been some discussions
iran has an investment panel back how we
do become more proactive because there
is an element as councillor Harvey has
said that you are beholden to projects
coming forward and whilst there are some
projects that have come forward we want
to be sure that there's a there's a
place to this stuff so that we are
actually ensuring the delivery of
affordable homes through the
contributions the developers quite
rightly make and so it is something that
will be very much fixed on the red
organizing investment panel and this
cabinet don't argue
thank you slightly off piste on this
particular topic
whereas we this monies tends to come
from developers asking for contributions
towards this County Council the budget
setting last two weeks or two years ago
they actually are indicating a setting
up their own housing company
the idea being of course that they have
bought a lot of land as we don't and
it's an option for us to perhaps explore
with them and see whether we can
leverage out more advantage in this
particular field
funny fair point counselor Kerrigan I
think that's something we should log for
future reference now any more comments
from members of the cabinet in that case
moving on to the recommendation on page
79 or cabbing it happy with the
recommendation on page 79 Thank You
members of cabinet moving on now in the
right order to item 7 revenue budget
monetary in once again councillor Harvey
Thank You mr. Jim the purpose of this
report is to inform the cabinet of the
revenue picture of the council's
finances for the first 10 months of the
year to the end of January 2020 if
members will turn to Appendix 1 on a
page 104 they'll see on the penultimate
line that the council had generated
surface in the net cost of the provision
of its services for the first ten months
of the year of five hundred and two
thousand pounds for the principal
reasons set out in the paper this
represents three point seven percent of
the budget of net cost of the services
provided during the period it's
estimated by budget holders however that
over the succeeding two months to the
end of March 2020 this position will
have changed resulting in a small
unfavorable amount of 64,000 pounds at
the end of the current financial year I
draw members attention to the substance
of paragraph 2.2 concerning a change in
practice that will be adopted about the
transfer between the counting years over
items that have hitherto been treated as
slippage this is intended to provide
greater clarity for members about when
projects are realistically expected to
be completed certainly 20 questions
members may have I asked that the
information in this report is noted
councillor Cargill
thank you just very briefly
section three one five page 98 I just
wonder if you could perhaps just give us
a little update as regards why the
information technology shows unfavorable
position on that one it mentions the
cessation of work with South stats
Tiffany if you could just a little
update on that I'll pass that to mr.
George thank you and show me now yeah
thank you thank you that there was but
there is a budget in the current year
for income from South staffs for a joint
or shared service that is no longer the
case so we won't be receiving thank you
okay without any further questions
Kelsey Junod a couple of questions
aren't specific questions and then one
more general if you won't don't mind one
is on the the policy three point one
point one the favorable position of two
hundred and two thousand etc is that
unspent budget in respect of the the
delay with them at the SA P I just
wondered if you could just inform me on
that one they the strategic allocations
policy size allocation policies and
secondly only 3.1.3
it's not split i'm just wondered I would
find it useful to know the difference
between which part of that budget it was
the increased members allowance and
which was caused by investigation costs
and then on the more general one is
perhaps I could come back on that one
mr. Hale are you going to take this or
is this counselor Harvey and
there's the splits you talked about we
can certainly provide that to members as
an update and they know what's bit on
the those two items is in terms of the
the policy and the on spend budget on
the planning Inspectorate examination
again I can investigate that and come
back to you on the details are you
content 204 mr. Hill to get back to your
council Junod and then on the more
general one and I just wanted to take up
something that councillor Curtis had
asked during the last council meeting
which is about in the what meetings have
what lobbying has been done to the
government on revenue budget monitoring
and whether you're able to update us on
whether any further meetings have taken
place or whether Robert generique has
actually replied to our revenue
situation at this council I have not yet
had a response from the Secretary of
State that account said the lobbying
we've done has not moved on since I last
reported full council but we will
continue to lobby as and when we see MPs
would you would you be able to keep it
keep us updated please or my colleagues
any lobbying because it's so important
to this council it's important I think
to every council right councillor kettle
the section one if I have one officer on
the performance he's reporting when we
looked at the variants at the end of
period eight we were one hundred and
seventeen thousand pounds away when he's
now reduced that to thirty thousand
which i think is a very much better
position to be in so congratulations
21.1 can I just say that this must be a
watershed cabinet meeting where
well the chairman actually congratulates
the section one five one officer can
sleep a bit where it stood mr. German
leader I think I'm entering an alternate
universe here actually now with that I
think just to Picasso the Juliet's
benefit as far as I understand and
unless the policy officer in the court
is going to tell me different that
variant around planting spectra it's not
the site allocations plan because we
were not due to be even under the
current timetable to be before the plan
indeed spectra in this financial year so
it's not SAP the questions are we happy
with the recommendations on page 97 the
grade Thank You members of cabinet there
been no issues arising from the
revealing scrutiny no report from
cabinet committees Part II is on block
items which are to receive on the
minutes so that is strategic policy
advisory group so just to go through
made strategic policy Advisory Group
minutes mobile development working group
minutes and stratford-on-avon market for
and minutes so can we receive and note
all of those members of cabinet there
being no urgent business there is one
item of urgent business and that means
we need to exclude the public it's sorry
it's urgent and it's confidential which
is why we're excluding the public so
pursuant to section 108 brackets for of
the Local Government Act 1972 as amended
the public be excluded from the
remaining business of the meeting in
view of the fact that the name
the proceedings will be such that if the
public were present there would likely
be disclosure to them of exempt
information under paragraph 3 of part 1
of schedule 12a to the said act as
amended
thank you